everybody it's gary vaynerchuck this is
the pod sessions this is our eighth
edition of this format where I bring in
three individuals and we shoot the [ __ ]
about different things find out what
they're obsessed about talk a little bit
about marketing and branding talk a
little bit about their worlds and so I'm
very excited to have three individuals
here they're all very attractive so if
they're listening if you're listening on
the podcast and not watching the YouTube
you've made a huge mistake and I'm gonna
let them all introduce themselves so why
don't we start with the lovely lady to
my left thank you my name is Charlie
Arnold known in the WWE world as Charlie
Caruso yes I'm an announcer for WWE I do
the interviews on Monday Night Raw and
I'm a studio host for the WWE Network
awesome we'll get into how that happened
of course I'm Erik Jones I Drive the
number 20 car in the Cup Series for Joe
Gibbs and how long have you been in the
Cup Series I was my second year okay and
how old are you 22
I know you know I just I did a
askgaryvee show with Kyle Busch and we
were talking a little bit about how
everybody's younger in the game so I'm
excited to get into that where were you
born where'd you grow up Michigan
Michigan awesome cool thanks for being
here and then the michigan race is
coming up right yeah now this weekend
next weekend do you feel extra pressure
when you're there
I'm not actual pressure but I'd like to
win there that's like your homies from
the grade school come through I'm Ty
Dillon I Drive the 13 Geico Chevy in the
Monster Energy Cup Series I'm 26 and we
were both rookies together so it's our
second season here and you're you're you
know I know from afar just like looking
at my social like you're you've been
like very good at adapting to the new
world is that a big passion of yours
yeah and it started from you honestly I
had my first daughter this offseason and
so sitting around with her when she's a
little baby I was sitting on the phone
my barber actually told me he's like hey
you got to check out Gary Vee you got
that kind of attitude just like him you
gotta check out his content that spurred
me into I bought I think the first thing
I did I don't know why but first thing I
did was bought two tickets to South by
Southwest knowing that I wanted to get a
videographer to start capturing content
of what I liked
then I met Joseph put out an Instagram
video saying hey and this is kind of
from your PlayBook to say and hey
anybody young wants to go out and video
my life and see what I do and capture
content for me for a full year and do I
think I said 36 events with me we're
gonna go and have some fun
did that started a vlog series and it's
just kind of gone from there and just
it's been huge for me and in my career
and what I'm doing um okay what I want
to do now is go back around try to row
start with you this is my favorite part
this is probably why I did the show cuz
I think this is just this is what I did
in real life at dinners with friends and
in business and it's my favorite part of
show I want to know what you're
currently obsessed with now this can be
like something that's going on in NASCAR
Truck Series or the WWE but I also think
it's super interesting if it's like
refined increasi riyal or like a new
shampoo or like you found your buddy
from third grade and you're on a text
chain like right now like random ass
[ __ ]
what are you obsessed with I'm obsessed
with saying yes right now I started a
new cake a few weeks ago where I say yes
to pretty much anything and it's kind of
been a it's been a great time you know I
I kind of got into a routine where I
always feel like my life got very
routine and you know I would come home
from work I would watch some Netflix I
would you know eat my meal prepped
dinners and I just it got kind of boring
and I was like what's going on here like
why am i living such a complacent
lifestyle when I'm in one of the
greatest cities in the world and I have
so many opportunities at my fingertips
in a friend had mentioned to me that she
started saying yes to more and I was
like you know what I'm gonna try that
and I have been so busy this summer now
with just so many different types of
things I've met so many people and it's
all because I've started saying yes to
things I love that I'm such a big book I
have a lot of content on yes when it
comes to business but when it comes to
life that makes so much yes good for you
what's the most ridiculous thing you've
done in your yes journey
oh um let's see I just traveled to Ibiza
a few weeks ago it was a trip that I
wanted to take for so long but it's one
of
like blast but it's oh I know it was a
blast you know and uh you know I said
yes to a lot of things while I was there
it also led to me having a blast yes but
it wasn't you know I was there for two
and a half days and I was like what's
better this day and a half too much do
it and it was so much fun and I met a
ton of cool people who live in New York
who have already like connected with
since I've been back and it's been great
good for you
what do you obsessed with my man I'm
right now motorcycles I don't know why
yeah I you know given that you grow you
know for a lot of us that maybe did not
grow up in racing or car culture it
seems that's a that's an easy jump but
is this a new thing for you like you're
into them yeah it's new is everybody
around you like oh [ __ ] that's real
dangerous yeah everybody says it's a
very bad idea
like motorcycles genuinely make like the
math I like things that are logical like
I'm very fascinated that more people
will die from texting and driving in
tomorrow than from terrorism in the next
five years in America yet the Delta of
how we talk about it right yeah the
motorcycles are son of a [ __ ] yeah like
that the other one I love is hippos and
sharks like hippos kill so many [ __ ]
people and sharks were scared shitless
and they kill a gay people so why'd you
get into it um I want one I mean number
one what you like saw some dude on
Instagram on a motorcycle like it's you
know your buddy tell you know I so I
wanted a motorcycle instead of a car
when I was 16 okay and I I'd saved up my
own money to buy a car but that got shut
down very quickly yes when you were 16
you saved the money to buy your own
motorcycle that's why I want mom's like
[ __ ] you yeah yeah okay it might have to
wait why well cuz your team doesn't want
it I don't think they appreciate it
no I get it right I mean you know it's
funny uh my brother AJ and I've started
Vayner sports
we're only repping football players but
a lot of guys a lot of teams want
motorcycle clauses literally motorcycle
clauses well Ben Roethlisberger member
yeah I do what football team do you like
lions
and I'm so [ __ ] proud of you - god I
was sitting like a cobra in the grass
I'm like if this [ __ ] dude from
Michigan doesn't say Lions because he
wasn't supporting the local team cuz
they've sucked [ __ ] his whole life yeah
I'm not gonna like him as much now I
like you twice as much no teams but
Monday night opener this year Jets Lions
really yes I did because I love the Jets
more than I love everything while you're
sticking with the team 200 I mean
personal it's a ridiculously terrible
Monday night game September 17th you're
done with the season is that here it
will be in Detroit oh yeah I'll be home
[Laughter]
me I've had a couple things that
obviously got my daughter so watching
her grow has been awesome raising right
that's the first one first year is just
nuts yet it's just it's blown you're
scared shitless right definitely a day I
remember when my daughter was born I'd
come home like late from work and like
19 times I'm like like out of nowhere
I'm like she's not breathing I just have
to go she's gonna die if they're not
crying you're more worried yeah that's
the first change the second one is don't
play to the crowd
tell me something weird weird okay so
though it's gonna sound general and
first okay it's gonna get real so
specific so football and American
football American football that's
football
I'm a die-hard Carolina Panthers fan
okay grew up born or raised North
Carolina yeah but to the point where I
will watch breakdown every film of every
game throughout the season and watch
Phil make notes and because that's what
you do for your own sport right yeah
like you've watched order yeah yeah
prepared and everything but I have
dreams one day after the sport of being
a general manager of a football team or
owning a team not I don't think I want
to own I think I want to run personnel
so I go in and make notes of every
practice practice things that I would
see different do different we have a kid
we represent him Kyle Allen who's on yet
right now trying to make the team and
the third quarterback who I think is
really like a diamond in the rough he
was like one of the top he was like
people when he was 17
I was gonna go number one overall in
this draft anyway you went undrafted and
Carolina signed him you DFA but it was
really unbelievable to like do the
homework on the circumstances of what
happened to him at Texas A&M in Houston
it's got the narrative to really work
out I'm hoping he sticks in Kerala he
came in after her Manziel right
yeah and he but then another kid to
follow there's so much I didn't you know
I I grew up in the Northeast where
college football is nothing for me it
was it was the NFL the NBA WWF in my day
but I had no idea how much the boosters
really drove [ __ ] in college football I
just saw Kyle cuz I went and watched a
training camp live on Monday so what
drove moral hardcore I'm hardcore
same thing with baseball love analytics
of baseball I salute you Lana Braves
closest one and there's been like talk
of Charlotte getting a team that's right
near her house if that if that happened
I would be insane I don't know what I
would do with my career that I'm got
going now in NASCAR but man it'd be big
my wife wouldn't like it but uh let's go
to origin stories let's paint a picture
for everybody let's do a two three
minute for a minute who are you were you
born how'd you get into what you're into
what are you into blah blah blah
alright I was born in Indianapolis okay
honest so I I was uh you know I've been
around racing you know good portion of
my life go to the Indy I know it's not
NASCAR but I've been going to Indy 500
my whole life yep
and I went on to work in television I
went to American University always knew
I wanted to work in television never
look knew exactly which path I wanted to
take but I always said I wanted to be
the next Oprah that was always like my
big thing growing up so I'm and someone
actually just commented on my photo
today like Charlie or Oprah and I was
like best compliment I've ever gotten in
my life and of course now it's on an
Instagram photo but um do you want to
hear a really fun fact you should go
look at Oprah's first Instagram photo
ever really okay keep going
um so I graduated with a broadcast
journalism degree from American when two
honey was out of control in college or
like were you like super focused I was
I was pretty focused I ain't I was I was
in a sorority and we had like our
parties here you know that Chi omegas do
not drink do not drink whatever really
we drank okay no see I had a good time
but I was always super I'm a super type
a to a fault
god I'm right 3.95 gph always cute but
I'm gonna be the next Oprah [ __ ] you
jock Shaunie yeah and I tried to skip
class once in college I freaked out I
ran to class no attendance was even
taken that's how I was so understood
went to Huntington West Virginia for my
first job one-man band reporter carried
all my [ __ ] with me you know went and
interviewed people about overdosing on
bath salts it was a very interesting
terrain in West Virginia yes I went on
to Kansas City Missouri still reporting
news there went back to Indianapolis my
hometown that's when I got into sports
sports anchor sports reporter and then
from there WWE saw my work asked me to
eye on a local like Network yeah I was I
was working for the Fox station there
doing sports reporter yeah yep in like
the culture playing the Browns this week
exactly okay and WWE I was actually the
way it happened I was backstage at
Smackdown it was in Indianapolis and I
ran into the head of talent relations
his name is Mark Carano
and at this point my contract with
Indianapolis had just expired I didn't
want to renew it and so I said hey I
recognized you from the show total divas
which is that reality show and I said
I'm a sportscaster would you mind taking
a look at my work and he said sure you
know didn't really follow up with me so
I reached out again a few months later
and he's like you're good I like you I'm
gonna pass us along so then he passed
along to Michael Cole who I know you
know who he is and from there they had
me come audition and the rest is history
Here I am good for you yeah did you grow
up watching wrestling at all I was a fan
at the beginning of middle school so
like sixth seventh grade I'm in the
Attitude Era got it right so there's one
called like everybody cared about
everybody loved it and so who are your
favorite sound like I mankind or let me
know the rock is I'm still obsessed with
the rock like I secretly cuz he's
secretly Oprah oh no Ross is actually
Oprah right oh yeah okay she's fantastic
so still love him he's amazing or just
my brother lying
yet yeah Lions fan from the start um I
got kind of an odd story for racing and
he's got a man I started when I was
seven so I started very young and
go-karts and I started moving up through
the ranks why why that's crazy
so was your family into it or do you
just humble into it no I
more so stumbled into it my family never
raced yeah I was always a fan of cars
and um my mom actually got me into it
got me started in it so uh so we get
going right away I'm like was that good
right away or did I like it I mean
immediately I liked it right away I
loved it
and I guess I was so much decent off had
I mean we won some races but from there
I started moving up into some lower
stuff outside a NASCAR late models they
call them around that area and I was
racing there until I was about 16 and I
got an opportunity actually from Kyle I
was racing against him and he came down
and raced one of those races you know
there's no rules in racing you can go
back around whatever series you want and
we're racing each other like work on
something it's almost like a triple a
thing or two giving love to the
community or like what it's a mix of
many things it's just a totally that
that series that type of racing we're
running is a very different car than
NASCAR's right yeah I think it's kind of
a respect back to the sport cuz it's
still not easy to go back and beat those
guys who run that car every single
weekend at that same track and that
makes sense and it's and it's a fun
thing too because it gets back to your
so like your initial roots so like when
Kyle comes and visits and he's already
in the big series like is that fun
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah there's no this big deal I mean
like you know it's like when Kershaw
gets hurt and there's a triple-a start
in New Mexico and everyone's like holy
[ __ ] yeah I love that I love that part
of triple-a baseball or double-a
baseball like when it's a small town or
what have you and like rehab pretty cool
yep yeah anyways what you raced in a
race with him and he just saw the talent
I ended up we raced at the end and I
ended up beating him in that race and he
gave me an opportunity and that was 2012
so 2013 to drive his truck yes
truck team there and I started racing
for him and we won a race in 2013 and he
gave me more opportunities and we kept
winning and and just moved into a
rollover Joe Gibbs Racing after that so
I mean there's a lot to it I could talk
about I'm sure I'm in a race yeah in
that series open up doors you kept
performing yeah and how is the big show
it's it's it's fun I love it but it's
it's tough transition to the car is so
different the car in the in the
competition competition level was very
very high in Cup I mean they're just
everybody's really good from first to
40th everybody's pretty good you know
the thing about Cup is at one point I
would say one yeah and it's just this
year I did crazy
I was not was that the goal this year
like I got to get a win on the board
yeah for me I mean I wanted to last year
we had an opportunity to win last year a
couple times and we didn't really
execute on it Kyle actually boiled one
of them yeah for me but you know I love
it I love how competitive he came up and
drove by me with about 50 laps to go and
just kind of pieces and I write second
so yeah yeah that's a big goal though
yeah I get a win you want to be a winner
yeah good for you what other thing what
other interests you have outside of
motorcycles what else outside of racing
TV shows I wish I was into cooking I
wish I was good at it no I love to golf
and yeah a golf a scuba dive I'm a scuba
diver I haven't been as much but I like
to scuba dive I'm a big big outdoors fan
that is like being outside doing
whatever love it man for me so I grew up
in a racing family my grandfather's
Richard Childress who owned Dale
Earnhardt's number three cars yep so
he's won seven championships with Dale
Earnhardt and then champ ship still
Xfinity series you did you broken like
let's just Friday a lot of people who
listen who don't know this 40 you kind
of grew up in royalty not even like yeah
I mean racing I mean in essence must be
stupid pressure somewhat but honestly my
grandfather my parents my dad raced also
they never pushed it on us I wanted to
play middle linebacker in football
that's what I wanted to do and then you
realized oh [ __ ] I'm too small fourth
grade seven junior peewee I was going to
peewee football and the hits were
getting harder like 13 this guy running
over me yeah I was like 13 and was
fortunate enough to have a grandfather
just that I could call and say hey I
want to try racing and I had seen kids
our age running around a track at
Charlotte Motor Speedway it's inside of
the track it's a quarter mile and from
that day got in the car for the first
time it was like whatever's in his blood
my dad's blood it clicked and really
well I remember leaving the track that
day and I knew I loved what I just did
and my grandfather and my dad my mom all
had a conversation with my brother night
we both saw at the same time he was 15 I
was 13 I made the call he might say it
but I made the call to get us our first
test we left the track and they said if
this is what you guys want to do you're
gonna commit to it if you really feel
like you want to do this we'll commit
and we'll try to make it happen and you
guys can race as much as you want but
you're gonna commit to doing it and do
it right
Kent yeah exactly and at that time at 13
is like for sure I'm in I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna be great and I committed we
committed and I ran 70 to 80 races a
year leaving school on Thursdays and
Fridays and doing all my homework Sunday
night get home Sunday night even when I
was 16 in high school I would go off my
dad would be at the racetrack helping
our Cup teams I would be racing a dirt
car out in the Midwest and drive home do
homework then then once I got in high
school I did more one-on-one classes
really just committed my life to tracin
and was successful all the way up
through you know and you get the haters
that say because it's your family but I
was able to be successful and you don't
get to the Cup Series just off of being
helpful way you don't last but now I
made it to the Cup Series I won in the
Truck Series my first year won two races
beat Kyle my first for my first win
which was huge cuz I look up to his
talent I mean he's he's our best driver
in the sport right now I feel like
talent wise and be him the first guy
that I just found out about who's mrz
yeah
he's got like a wrestling name that's
yeah I was like he's tearing it up last
year's yeah what's going on with these
three guys it sounds like I've won like
almost every [ __ ] races they're
dominating for sure is everybody else
pissed yeah yeah pretty much yeah so and
then one one early in the Xfinity series
one in Indianapolis was my my first win
there and to get a win at the Brickyard
was huge just so much history and now my
second year in Cup Series I'm not racing
for my grandfather's team I had race for
his team my whole career and chose just
because I'd ran Xfinity three years and
he had drivers on contracts for his jobs
and sponsor obligations and I felt like
I was ready
if collegues the next level and the team
is actually about everybody and that
story yeah and it's it's been really
awesome for me the team is still a
technical alliance so we share
information on my grandfather's team but
we are our own separate entity still all
the cars come out of a different shop
that's actually an hour away so been
raced for them for two years and we had
their successful most successful season
last year in my rookie season statistic
wise across the board and we're really
trying to build a program and it's it's
up and down like he said going from
Truck Series I won and was in my Ricky
gear was battled for a champ
all the way down to last race and got
got wrecked by a good friend now but
Kyle Larson making his first or second
start ever the Truck Series he wrecked
me and I lost the champ and he hated his
face for a while yeah now two years yeah
about two years and then I got to know
him a little bit better the same thing
Xfinity series was battling for
changeups and now in the Cup Series it's
like taking three steps and yeah it's so
much tougher and but we're battling I
feel like there's six this year the race
he won finished citizen yep I'm actually
filled in for Tony Stewart two three
years ago when he had a back injury and
finished sixth in his car but he started
the race he got out I got in the car and
rehearse six so unofficially I didn't
get the the finish for that since he
gets the he gets six place really the
person that starts yeah I cross the line
finished
yeah I wish I know it but it's been an
awesome career and then I've just been
trying to make the most out of this
moment in my life and with everything
yeah and and it found me here today
which is this is as you can tell I I'm
so excited this is really cool for me
flattered um actually let's make that
transition I know that Tyler got a hold
of you and your team and so I'm glad
you're here so for you Charlie how do
you think about social Instagram what do
you use what do you like how much of an
impact does it have what's good about it
what's bad about it I mean there's it's
such a wide spectrum from what's great
about it to what's terrible about it in
my opinion I mean it's one of those
things that's not going anywhere it's
getting bigger and bigger as the days go
by so I'm just trying to embrace it as
much I can I mean as far as building
I'll take me back to Taipei you we don't
drink no drink what would yours really
know yeah I know what did you use back
then anything nothing well yeah I mean I
was a little up on myspace was a kid
myspace I had the top a you know like
will you strategic about your top a
absolutely I mean you may be taking you
you did something wrong you're out of
there so when you would drop somebody
like Carol from science class from your
top eight and you came to school I think
I was an old man by the time myspace
came to made a difference yeah for you
young face eye contact was it like it
was it like a real thing oh yeah it was
very much like I think somebody owning I
thinks I needs to bring back the top
eight dynamic insult like I think I'm
new so I've actually been having this
weird feeling this just not a dream not
a daydream but this overall feeling that
we're on the feel like there's these two
girls somewhere in like the suburbs of
Denver working on an app I can feel it
like you know like the force I feel like
it's Star Wars I feel like I'm so in
tune with the social media zeitgeist
that I think we're on the verge of
something coming out and now I'm gonna
try to use my powers to make those kids
decide to make it more about top eight
dynamics like we we can't offend anybody
oh really political but like you you're
so you you believe even in this short 10
12 15 year window that the top eight
dynamic would not play in the current
state of like people offended about
everything about everything about
everything it's interesting I think you
know I think actually I you know I think
I think the country is very split now on
the defending to me I'm unbelievably
socially liberal and like think
everybody should love everybody but I
will say like eighth place trophies is
the bane of my existence like the thing
that I loved about like the thing that
I've loved so far talking about like all
this energy of like competitiveness and
things of that nature is I don't
understand how people want to put their
kids in situations where there aren't
winning and losing you you fundamentally
don't set them up for success
they're like finished yeah my dad never
let me win anything no yeah I mean I'm
like destroying my six year old son and
everything and like the whole family's
like bent out of shape like he's gonna
be a loser otherwise yeah I genuinely
believe that yeah I mean there was that
remember there was that big debacle over
the participation Awards remember it was
when was that a years ago good news I
have that as a macro thesis for like the
last 20 hours like I also think school
does that a lot
I actually think back to being type a
like student life there's been this
enormous push on being an entrepreneur
which I'm very in and winning in I
failed in school for a reason winning in
school is an incredible skill you figure
out the system yeah and you play it the
problem is much like the shift from
truck to the cup right being an
entrepreneur is literally like like
swimming versus cooking to being good at
school they're like completely different
and I think that fake environments is
what I call them are very very very
dangerous I mean as a matter fact you're
probably successful because your family
overcorrect it's not put you in a fake
environment because of the lineage and
the last name like that's the only way
you could be this happy and successful
yeah I yeah I almost over corrected in
the I was working on my car at certain
levels there was I had smaller teams and
other people and I had
they had more backing and capability you
had to because dude coming up who like
came out of left field from a different
place with not that background you can't
help it as a human you're gonna deploy
that cynicism and then and like and then
the you know like if you're the outsider
not with it that's the chip and if
you're in it
you've got the reverses it's definitely
the reverse percent so what do you want
to shove it in advice for small like the
i-told-you-so is the most [ __ ]
delicious flavor ever mm-hmm I'm
obsessed with it yeah do you feel that
now like you've like clearly you're on a
pretty big stage now yeah you've been
talking [ __ ] your whole life with your
friends that like I'm gonna be on TV
like clearly some of them like smiled in
your face but didn't think so
do you love coming back to India being
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] mm-hm you
know why I don't because I just got your
site well I mean I always knew that I
was gonna be successful I mean I I need
to give a [ __ ] what Karen said no I
didn't care about Karen Ferger you hate
Karen yeah I mean I always knew I was
gonna be successful whether you know
whatever path why I just I don't accept
failure I mean I'm telling you man I say
I'm type a it's it's a beautiful thing
because it it makes it so that I will
never accept failure as even a remote
possibility how do you make what's
what's the fine line between
determination and delusion I don't know
I think I think if you I don't I don't
think you can be delusional I mean if
you're willing to put the wool I don't
you've ever launched American Idol but
here hi Simon
I'm like the next beyoncé Wow very
exciting please sing bad like like
that's delusion okay right rights like
these guys came up with guys driving
their homies at 16 they're [ __ ]
stealing a beer from the 7-eleven after
a race and Rick looks at them and be
like [ __ ] I'm gonna be there one
day and they're through their heads
they're like I know this has no Sh you
have no shot
that's delusion true true I stand by the
way and by the way I'll be honest with
you it was funny to hear you pause a
little bit
I was literally laughing really fast in
my head I'm like I'm glad nobody's ever
asked me that question
cuz I don't know either like it's it's
super hard to think like it's it seems
like an incredible fine line
it's like into it
I feel like it's like more intuition
where whether you know you can keep keep
going you know and you know that you
don't want to give up because you know
you've got it it's like being honest
with yourself right I mean if you for me
like I'd be delusional for me to say oh
I'm gonna go on American Idol and even
have a chance at winning cuz I am an
awful singer I am the worst I'm really
but I but you're what I'm a great singer
seriously no no on a very serious note
because you're kind of jokes right now
do you think do you think you can sing a
little bit
no okay karaoke go-to karaoke song
should have been a cowboy but if you
have a skill set that you know you're
good at and you know and then you you
push in that direction I mean then do
you siblings know Wow and what kind of
like mom and dad situation did you have
I'm the best I mean yes my mother still
to this day like she calls me so many
times a day I'm like mom we've already
talked three times today I love you but
there's nothing left to say today let's
let's shut this down but um my mother
was always more they like doting and you
know everything I did was perfect which
she was the cheerleader yes okay dad
dad was the opposite and still is like
he will not really what you know what's
super interesting and I had this do you
think the polar opposites of how they
did it in that polling you were able to
develop the strength make the Diamonds
from that pressure yeah I think so
because you learn both behaviors just
one I think it could push you in a
certain direction but if you have both I
think that's blocks on that that my mom
was was definitely a cheerleader always
had the back of her babies and then my
dad was on the other side like no I
don't know make him do this right he's
gotta do it right and I think it carved
me a perfect pass to be Who I am now
what about for you um they were both
pretty hard on me
remote I was like I was really not a
good kid too like you were a straight
dick yeah I mean looking back yeah
pretty much why I wouldn't want to deal
with me
well yes you do let's get in the cycle
class here um like what was happening
like you were mad at the world
I thought it was funny I thought it
would I thought I was very funny and and
I hated school what and what you you
thought you were funny and you found one
or two other [ __ ] dick faces and then
guys created a crew yeah we were real
smart a lot of talking back yeah class
yeah yep to everyone and where are those
homies now I don't have a shot do the
michigan race go and have like a sign
like yo [ __ ] oh yeah yeah ok so back to
social yeah I mean what do you what do
you want me do I love it because you can
connect with so many different types of
people whether it's in your industry or
otherwise I mean I just started getting
more into fitness I just got my personal
training certification a few weeks ago
it's another area that I want to pursue
isn't one for your mind to wrestle like
being around it are you you know you
come in I heard you're back Yeah right
you're sportscaster you're right like
you know one point you're thinking call
Ross even what McMahon meant Jesse the
body Ventura used to be very very very
good at the announcer game you come in
thinking about those things you know and
who else knows what you were thinking
like SportsCenter like whatever you're
thinking but being in the culture of it
cuz you guys [ __ ] work hard like you
guys are on the road a lot has it
crossed your mind to wrestle I mean I'd
be lying if it say that it didn't I knew
it how well like meet this back to the
linebacker I think the thing about
wrestling that's interesting back to a
Rey Mysterio jr. or others is like you
may not have the size but you could find
a fly figure your way like mike from
[ __ ] real world like the myth like
like it just feels achievable ish yes
yeah I say it's not delusional oh it's
very delusional no to your point it's a
great jump in I think I think the
easiest way to get delusional is to be
suffocated in the culture
if you're there everything you just like
you know you saw you know you're just in
the bubble right it looks easy
I think NASCAR makes me laugh because I
know dudes like unlike football or other
things it's driving we do it yeah and so
like for a lot of people they don't play
that sport anymore they only did a long
time ago but they're still driving and
they're I'm sure all these idiots think
that they can do it well plus I mean
anybody can pick up set of golf clubs
and though they're not Tiger Woods right
yeah you can't just go hop in culture
right now to be very honest is actually
my game entrepreneur shell I mean every
single Instagram photo is entrepreneur
because they [ __ ] came up with a
brand name for t-shirts and made 15-2
shirts and think they were [ __ ] you
know gonna build a trillion-dollar
empire I mean the entrepreneur delusion
is really tough because unlike NASCAR or
being on TV or other sports nobody
really knows what's happening hmm
all those things are front-facing with
entrepreneurship you're like yeah I'm
working on my thing so you can't keep
score you don't see it until the end
which is why it's super dangerous
so anyways sorry we keep coming up Oh
keep running around so you love that you
can connect yeah it's free fitness thing
it's great to connect because not being
in that world you know like it's not
like I've worked my way up in that world
where I met people along the way it's
like now I'm just able to like find
people and connect with them instantly
which is really cool so I love that I
love being able to build my platform and
get exposure and being able to like
build my brand in the different sectors
that I'm interested in so I really enjoy
social media for those reasons and I
know that don't you like I don't like
the fact that everyone is getting very
I'm just one's getting stupider I mean
communication is suffering so much where
like you'll be in a room with all your
friends and you're all on your phones
and I'll like notice in a bit but let me
go on hold on let's talk about this
because I have a very very unique point
of view on this as someone who's older
than you three let me tell you what
friends did in 1999 when they were all
in a room we watched [ __ ] TV like
friends aren't supposed to be talking to
each other every [ __ ] second of every
minute and like that's what friends do
like we've when we're together a lot of
times were
talking every second so all of us
breaking into our phone and doing that
is what we used to do when we
collectively watch the show and yes to
your point maybe while we're watching
that wrestling match where you were like
oh that's funny haha and have that
collective but I I do think that we're
over scrutinizing our behavior in this
because the reality is is we always did
like people like Oh everyone's painting
a picture of their best selves and a PR
of themselves on social true let me tell
you how that used to work you'd go
outside and you talk to your neighbor
and they'd be like how are things go out
phenomenal Ricky is gonna be [ __ ] in
NASCAR is gonna be on TV and like
everything's great meanwhile that [ __ ]
dad's an alcoholic and everything like
we always front all that social media is
doing is exposing on digital what we
always were and do thoughts Charlie I
think that you're correct in a sense
that yes like we're all sitting in a
room and watching TV fine but people are
on their phones when they're walking
down the street people are other what
did you want them to do look at a
[ __ ] tree I mean you miss everything
that goes by though did you see that no
I'm sorry I was staring at an Instagram
picture that I've already looked at six
hotties see what the squirrel ate a
[ __ ] like this but but I'd rather see
[ __ ] world stars premiere a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like euro got it [ __ ] video
like this let me tell you what you're
doing that I believe is the most
interesting human condition we put the
past on a pedestal and we fear monger
the current and future it's just what we
do for example this you will remember
remember how outrageous what Miley Cyrus
did on the [ __ ] MTV Music Awards only
seven eight summers ago it was so
outrageous that's like a lame Instagram
post today yeah everything gets elevator
right a hundred percent every like we
are funny as a people like like listen I
understand your point I genuinely think
what's in my phone is more interesting
than the [ __ ] cloud shaped like a
[ __ ] unicorn fare and I think that
word like all like I think we're
demonizing it here's the good news
you couldn't do whatever the [ __ ] you
want you want to put your phone in your
[ __ ] little jean jacket here and
and look at oh look what has happened a
car drove by knock yourself out but I
think we're putting things of the past
on a pedestal and my point is humans
will pick what they want humans do what
they want to do so when I go out and see
a couple having dinner and they're not
both on the phone that tells me that's
not a good relationship not oh I hate
technology because I'm old enough
remembering going out to dinner and did
think it was interesting that I could
sit next to a couple and they wouldn't
say a [ __ ] word to each other the
whole dinner yeah and you know and I
didn't even understand it cuz I'm a big
talker my family it's very loving like
now I'm like oh [ __ ] and so to me
weirdly when I see people on the phone
I'm like oh thank God we have phones now
where people can do what they actually
want to do but do you ever find yourself
picking up your phone and going onto
Instagram let's say and just scrolling
and like it's mine let's like you don't
even realize you're on it then you're
like watching TV or going to you know
this and I don't even know why I'm gonna
[ __ ] times you went through Vogue at
13 that you saw 900 times yeah thank you
like we haven't changed what you going
through your Instagram feed you
literally went through [ __ ] Seventeen
magazine like nine hundred times and
that guess what that was the same [ __ ]
good news instagrams not like like so I
don't know what do you guys think about
this conversation or fear-mongering
technology or clearly not but are you
think I'm on the edge right I don't know
I'm excited to try I'd probably have a
flip phone if I could write you love
this like you're into that I gotta keep
that like it's really can [ __ ] shoot
a deer like like that right how do you
like I respect that that's where you've
taken it as an ideology what what do if
anything do you like about modern
technology
Netflix phones convenient yeah I mean
the convenience right right directions
anywhere I mean you can go online look
anything up right yeah it's all just to
cut you up real quick by the way they
love who's watching when I cut people
off literally I should never have guests
on any kind of show it's the only time
my audience is like you're such a
[ __ ] dick like just let somebody say
something but I want to say a story
because I got to get it off when I was a
kid on like you three [ __ ] faces when
you wanted to meet your friend after
school it was
like this kind of [ __ ] yo alright so
4:30 at the [ __ ] mall fountain and
crazy [ __ ] would happen like you know a
car accident would happen somewhere and
the purse would be late and you're like
well I guess josh is not gonna come this
actually happened in the 90s anyway go
ahead so you like direction you were
saying oh cool that I'm phone apps I can
use Waze and get the [ __ ] place I
mean the convenience is great yeah I
don't like it's taken out you know you
can look up any answer quickly I don't
know if I necessarily like that all of
them interesting I'd say I could see
where don't kill Danny by that like I do
yeah I mean it kind of takes away some
general knowledge things like
everybody's yeah but then they were
putting general knowledge on a pedestal
and actually in essence it was a
commodity yeah so you're going to the
place I'm very passionate about with
school which is like I do not want to
send my kids to school to memorize [ __ ]
right when the [ __ ] answers on the
phone yeah like what are we doing here I
always see I was right on the tip of
that when I was in school like you could
you could kind of look stuff up right
away
yeah I didn't have a font like we don't
have smartphones you right of course at
that part of school but so what do you
use if anything now
nothing social media well yeah I go on
them all yeah I come I personally use
like looking at chicks and stuff yeah of
course I mean I relationship are never
gonna be the same because guys rose look
at this Hawker I'm gonna DM er well good
news that's what guys always did these
hot babes are at their fingertips and so
like they're like hey you're all right
but you're sitting excited come out like
this way so make up look at this girl
with her tits out yeah but girls do that
too mmm I don't think they do it like
guys do right they're like look that guy
looks super like well often doing his
[ __ ] thing you're all in yeah well I
am I have one like small doubt of it and
that's like small I haven't obviously
had a child of course kids being on
phones early like I think there's a
certain level of learning how to have a
conversation look at me and I that gets
lost with throwing an iPad but let's
let's talk about this you know that your
grandfather has things like that that
you laughed out of the building like to
me what's super interesting is and I
mean this this is
smart talk not like me trying to be
funny why does looking somebody in the
eye when you have a conversation why
does that need to be on a pedestal
because I'll tell you as a historian of
communication people [ __ ] on the
telephone because the proper way to do
it was to write a proper letter mm-hmm
like I think what's again this is a
theme and I'm gonna bring it up again
it's fascinating that we put things in
the past on pedestals and we looked I
think it's incredible like I'll be very
honest I'm very different than that I
have two young children I want my kids
on screens 24/7 I'm not kidding and let
me tell you why what world do you think
we're they're gonna live in that world a
hundred percent go away you know and
like just like watching film or getting
in at 13 or 15 like the reality is like
here's what it is when you specially
when you have that nice little girl when
she's one you go right into protection
mode and you start getting worried
remember MySpace was gonna get everybody
kidnapped at the mall yeah like like you
everybody goes to the negative instead
of the positive let me give you a
positive that nobody talks about there
are millions of children right now young
adults who got into a high school or
junior high where it didn't click
something happened the normal [ __ ] that
we all grew up with right like the wrong
person picked on you you liked somebody
they broke up with you in a weird way
and something happened and your brand
aka your reputation got affected and in
the past you had nowhere to go the fact
that that kid could go home right now
put on twitch and hang out with his or
her homies right across the world is so
powerful yet we think social medias
bullying kids they said no no kids are
not being taught to lose and so they
don't know how to deal with that versity
so by the time you get to 14 when
everybody just defaults into being a
dick for a [ __ ] survival and we were
all there you know they're like oh [ __ ]
I don't know how to handle this not it's
bullying social media has so much good
to it of people fight if you're a
theater nerd but you're not you're in
the deep NASCAR or NFL right if you're
you know but you can find your whole
tribe on Instagram it's very powerful
but we default into the negative versus
the positive like looking somebody in
the eye like help me here like you know
I get it I saying that you want your
kids to respect people that's different
as a matter of fact again I think
obviously we have a lot of issues in the
air in our society right now but I think
the best way for people to respect
people is to get to know about them and
I think that exposure that the Internet
does allows them the potential to
respect it also allows them if they're
Mis parented to hate anyway I just think
our kids are gonna live in a massive
technology world where they're gonna be
interacting with robots and I promise
you every person listening and everybody
thinking here right now this iPhone and
all the technology is gonna seem lame as
[ __ ] in 15 years because the same way
that everybody who's listening that grew
up with a pager which was [ __ ] crazy
and you were a narc if you had one or a
drug dealer like you know and you know
that is a piece of [ __ ] now right and so
I don't know I just don't think you can
stop technology and I think I'm trying
to have this conversation because I
think that you know even at the young
age that you guys are at there's this
quick trigger to look at the negative of
it and I just definitely believe that
life is about perspective delusion
versus determination I do think that we
need to take a step back and realize how
much good is being done because of this
because the world has never been better
when you look at the macro stats of
poverty and everything health everything
and all of it's on the back of
technology so you wouldn't you would
think it's not weird if somebody didn't
look cute so I'm stuck on this one
looking someone in the eye
you wouldn't think it's weird if you
talk somebody and they're talking like
this but that's not what people do what
people act nobody without a phone in
their hand looks first of all that's
actually true some people do not look
you in the eye because they're shy
without a phone but I'm not super
affected by that nor would I be affected
if I was talking to somebody right now
and they were texting while I was
talking because I've done it as well and
I don't want to be a hypocrite and I and
I also don't like I think people have
ego way too much ego like who the [ __ ]
are you that like somebody can't
disrespect you like [ __ ] you you know a
firm handshake like if somebody gives
you I like up firm handshake right cuz I
think it's me along the same listen but
I'll go with but I've but I could think
of two guys right now who have one of
the like two very firm handshakes and
they're [ __ ] soft and [ __ ] losers
yeah so like to me it's like what is
like okay so where we going with this
firm handshake like
both those guys are [ __ ] soft they
suck there's no respect for them
whatsoever they're [ __ ] handshakes are
[ __ ] legit and their [ __ ] jawline
tremendous so listen here's what I would
say I don't want a [ __ ] on tried and
true and tradition I come from an
Eastern European background I've got a
lot of things but I care about the
essence of what they meant you want to
not look me in the eye and not have a
firm [ __ ] handshake but be a respectful
awesome human being I [ __ ] with you you
see where I'm going I think we've
transferred that though things were
actually trying to say into these little
things and then we hold the things on
the pedestal where the intent you know
listen I really don't want to go there
but I'm gonna go there it's why I'm
fascinated by the kneeling and the
national anthem thing I fascinated by
how a conversation can change from what
it is
and so that's how I think about things
what's the point of looking somebody in
the eye oh oh grandpa you'd want respect
I'm with you respect matters but the
amount of people that look you in the
eye and firm handshake and steal money
on the back cheat on their girl on the
back do all this stuff so what are we
talking about here
right so it's really interesting I just
landed from London 40 seconds ago I
watched yeah like I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] super wired up of like a nine
hour flight I'm nine hours ahead of like
five or six hours ahead um I watched the
but there was no Wi-Fi which is the
weirdest well there's no weird Wi-Fi my
whole world goes bonkers
so hey thank God I caught up on all my
work cuz I use my inboxes my work and
then I'm like [ __ ] I have time someone
alright so I'm like maybe I'll watch a
movie which is very rare for me to ever
be off so I watched the paterno HBO
movie the Joe Paterno joke ah right
respect tradition 61 years 45 coach and
you know I was watching I was like this
is super powerful the religion of
college football people reacted to over
the well-being of ten-year-old boys
being raped by a man and you know what's
funny I get it cuz I don't wanna be a
hypocrite because guess what when it
comes to New York Jets
I'm not irrational we're just a favorite
New York jet all-time al tune really I
don't know if you know who that is he's
old but he's my favorite I've
they're behind Randy the Macho Man
Savage he was my favorite wrestler of
all time but we're not Broadway Joe man
mainly cuz I didn't see him play
I love the legend of Broadway Joe I love
that he was the coolest [ __ ] dude of
all time and all that stuff but uh
mainly on the back of that I just didn't
see him play
right it was just so much more affected
by what you see play let's do a little
cross-pollination did you you know
Indianapolis Racing was it more Formula
one culture or an and that whole sport
or did you care about NASCAR did you
care about
I mean Indy car was was the big dog but
week I covered I covered the Brickyard a
few times like were you a Danica fan um
yeah of course I'm huge right here I
mean she's she's a ginger age oh yeah
yeah oh yeah for sure love Danica and I
love what she's forming now and just
like turning her career under like such
a you know much more so that's your real
thing
I mean that was your what I'm gonna ask
them about the wrestling fandom or not
NFL's
your coachman work yeah we'll talk about
that in a second because there's two
very hardcore Jets Colts playoff games
of the last decade and I want to talk to
you about three actually in the last two
decades wrestling I was into a big I
think
same era that whole stone-cold or were
you more wcwc because you're the sound
yeah and like staying in all those guys
yeah yeah you were that and that was
kind of like I was the age of my parents
like you probably don't need to watch
too much of this then it was like okay
whatever watch it yeah I was all in for
a while was your favorite wrestler of
all time
I love sting sting he's in the racket
lechery of course huge nothing on a big
knob never was no never got you all
right so we're gonna go to a Lions Jets
game and I'm gonna take you into summer
I'm gonna take you to SummerSlam
no you're in season during SummerSlam i
survivor so you guys what does that
still Thanksgiving mmm-hmm I was never
big into wrestling or boxing or anything
like that
no dude I went to the Mayweather
McGregor fight not wrestling obviously
that was a cultural event yeah you were
into that yeah I was this way it was
awesome the atmosphere is great just
being in Vegas
that's right like I saw I didn't see the
event that was WrestleMania where she
popped out first yeah she got really
good reviews yeah no she's great she's
actually like one of the most humble
down-to-earth people that I've come
across I mean she's you would never
guess that she was just inducted the
into the UFC Hall of Fame because she's
super cool she's just super
down-to-earth not she's trying to build
her respect in the game right yeah yeah
it's a Randy Savage over over Ric Flair
I mean I don't know a lot
I loved Ric Flair I was more of a I'm a
northeast kid so it's more WWF than kind
of the NWA WCW the stuff that was going
down south but I watched both a lot what
I used to love when one would switch
leagues and just have a new character
the whole thing that was always like fun
and this was pre-internet so you didn't
know what's coming now you know
everything yeah back then you just wake
up Saturday be like oh [ __ ] Billy Jack
Hayes is now here late would be like so
crazy that's awesome thank you lord
this guy when he first came so like for
example let's talk about the Ultimate
Warrior I used to watch ESPN Houston
like like Texas wrestling where he was
the dingo warrior down in Texas against
the Von Erichs so when he came to the
WWF like I could make that connection
that was like I was really really
interested I'm still like like when the
Hall of Fame event was here like I'm
still like I'm so busy I could soon no
kaneki mean the joke I made about
watching a movie so I'm a little bit
behind it but a lot of the WWE guys are
starting to DM me on Instagram like and
like it's super fun and like I'm trying
to like figure out how to hack my time
to watch a little bit more because I
want to get back into it cuz a lot of
them are giving me love which makes it
fun which ones
Sheamus has hit me up why it has hit me
up like so like it's coming and it's
like super fun written Rey Mysterio like
it's super fun yeah your hockey fan I
grew up a huge Rangers fan so like
literally the reason we're in my office
right now
and when I was when we built this office
two corners and the other one is a much
better view like it's a Hudson you can
see the [ __ ] Statue of Liberty and
look at Jersey I'm such a proud Jersey
boy but the Knicks and Rangers like like
the guard like the garden is that's
where I want the 94 Rangers won me my
first championship when I was
18 and I like watched all four sports
which means like since I was six so it's
like 48 seasons of losing Jets Knicks
Rangers Yankees because the Yankees
weren't good when I was a kid so I was a
huge hockey fan yeah that's that
territory right are you big that's real
religion huge huge what can I get for
you guys real quick and then we'll
bounce out here anything I can answer
for you for me just me planning like I'm
looking in the future always most
drivers post driving yet post-rock ahead
like 35 40 45 35 okay if I get me up to
45 be awesome yeah and but I don't want
to stop there I want to keep the path
going like the things that I need to do
too
when I hang the helmet up at 45 the next
day I'm stepping into it so I think I
think one thing that social really works
out for all three of you that I would
tell you that's its answer for all three
of you become religious about the
audience I think the thing that you know
Vincent the whole crew there is done and
if you think about when NASCAR does well
or doesn't do well or other sports do
well or duck don't do well when I think
about my career are the things we do at
this company from marketing I don't
think people care about the audience
enough at times they get caught it's not
that they're bad it's that they get into
their own dynamics they go inside they
don't become consumer centric I think if
you keep reading those comments keep
engaging with it keep putting a content
you'll be unbelievably stunned on how
easy the answers will come of what to do
because it's been said to you in the
trenches got it what do you have fun I
admire you because your network is so
huge and I feel like everybody is you
know oh I've exchanged you know a DM
with Gary before oh I've you know seen
him here and it's like everybody knows
you and said maybe some type of
interaction with you although it may be
small but you just seemed to be able to
create such a network and keep it where
as I feel like I could meet someone who
I'm like oh my god I met this this girl
yesterday she was awesome I want to grab
dinner with her in a week later I'm like
oops I forgot
I don't even have that many people in my
life yeah millions I mean you just
managed to curate these relationship
with them and and keep them going and
building them and I just it's almost
overwhelming to me look I think I think
much like anything else like every one
of us does something that is
overwhelming to each other for me people
have always come natural I you know it's
really funny if you think about earlier
10 minutes ago what I was talking about
with people interaction it's crazy
because my love in life is other people
and so it's probably why I got to like
oh it's the respect isn't the eye or to
shake it's the truth you know look my
truth is like I really like people
people and it starts with like closest
to the Sun like I would die for my
family and then out from that you know I
think my employees that are in here will
tell you like there's just a different
level of how I manage it cuz I just like
them more like I don't even know what
else really it's not super complicated I
want to be admired and like I like
admire them I give respect right off the
bat you have to lose it it's not like
you got to earn it it's that lack of ego
that I think you know I have so much
confidence that I am bravado and a
personality that pours one way but I
think in my actions I really the thing
I'm proud of is the ability to have
humility because I never think I've died
always honestly I think everything I've
done yesterday back means nothing it's
very weird it really works for me like I
just I get it but like I don't I don't
I'm in the reverse I don't romanticize
the back you know like it's probably why
I push against this room maybe like
psychoanalyzing myself right now my god
[ __ ] that makes sense I think people are
the 100% are a way of life like starting
with like the people that are that come
to your funeral like and think about I
start with the end like who do you
compel enough that yeah like do you know
I think going to a funeral is the most
fascinating thing in society because I'm
surprised the funerals I was willing to
not go to this is I'm being very real
with everybody I have a cycle like I'm
fascinated by some of the people I did
business with in the liquor business
over the last 20 years I was very young
as a kid and like kind of like you know
generational family business I think
it's very interesting in a world where
we're all selfish and doing our thing
who's brought you so much value that you
will just stop
obviously your family members but then
what
like right it's just super interesting
and I've basically been living my life
for a pretty long time now on can I be
so great that everybody stops thing
comes to my funeral and you know it's
funny I've always been like for a long
time I never talked about it then I
talked about him like is that douchey
like what is that and now I kind of like
I'm super happy I'm like that it means
that like I want to do the right thing
and like for the right reasons not the
makeup of what respect and admiration
and kindness is but the actual truth
behind it so yeah I value and I'm also
grateful I'm you know you know unlike
actually listening to all three of you
you know because of what you wanted to
do there was always a thought if you
guys became big-time drivers if you got
on television you knew that you would
have some level of Fame and could
whether you dreamed about it you know
for TV you dreamed about it for you you
could have much it could've been a
little bit different but you just knew
you'd be known for me I always wanted to
be a businessman and that didn't mean
that anybody would ever know you so for
me all this attention came when I was
not looking for it and I was well into
my late 30s when it became like oh this
is gonna get like like I think I'm gonna
be the next Oprah in like white dude
form you know and so like I you know and
so I uh there's a level of gratitude
that makes me like the fact that people
wanna know who I am
seems weird and amazing and all that
what do you got bro I think for me
probably a basic question for you so
basics good you know we have so many
sponsors and so yes we're trying to make
happen that's right that's right around
how do we how do we support them and
show them on social media without
looking she's you know I mean your basic
question is actually the question yeah
so good job I think it's communication I
think first of all right now you're
young and like the leverage you have is
different than let's say a top five
racers 10 15 years in with championships
but it will always be communication I
think whether it's your makeup at this
young of an age or when you have the
leverage the right answer is hey you're
my sponsor
you want me to do good for you I don't
want to do what you want me to do on
social which then means it's gonna feel
inauthentic which then means it's dead
if I had never worn a pair of k-swiss
when I was a kid I would have never done
the collaboration thank God I mean I
mean this is not a joke cuz I would have
wanted to thank God I had won and I'm
trying to think I always I've still been
battling with my hand I try to like find
and the antique reco if you're watching
this sixth grade when you wore those
weird red sneakers with Leafs on them
and I made fun of you and I apologize
for that
well did I have k-swiss or is that
adidas I need your help on that cuz I
can't remember but I definitely remember
the one case with tennis sneakers I had
I think a lot of anticipate a sponsor to
that maybe isn't your favorite power
drink or you know what have you that's
what you what I think it is is
authenticity
huh you know one I think you need to be
posting what you want to be posting
obviously you need to be able to deal
with the ramifications like if you say
things that are not gonna fly like
you'll have to deal with that but I do
think when you're obligated to do like a
post like I would like ready macho man's
my favorite wrestler if I had to post
this I would do some sort of post I'd be
like like a weird face and in my copy
I'd be like here's my Ultimate Warrior
story number one when he beat macho man
I [ __ ] hated him for it right number
two when he came I loved him as the
dingo warrior and his battles with Rick
Rude in the Texas League that later went
to like I would tell the truth right
like and so that's the you know there I
mean there's people in sports that are
that are being represented or have a
sponsorship deals with a product that
they you know for example we work with
Pepsi and I told Pepsi and say it loud
right now they're currently a
multi-million dollar prop hi
I grew up drinking coke right you know
like like I just think the truth is
always the leverage my case whistie oh
my sneaker deal almost died because in
the claws
I would not sign that I would only work
a smoothness even though they give me
millions of dollars they make the tubes
okay Swiss is that them what's that the
two dupes yeah that's shoes it's two no
I'm trying to think though I don't think
so what are the tubes or circles you
know on the bottom of shoe oh I think
that's like you mean that little look
that's Nike right there no no no you
think it's about right we'll look at
after
don't know yet he's talking with those
circles that like this right yeah these
right yeah yeah yeah you have those no I
don't have those but you want some
series we'll just go home guys thank you
so so so much for being on the show
everybody's watching follow these three
support their careers thank you again
[Music]